this game lasts so I'll just play and
we'll see where I got to and then I'll
explain to you guys who might not know
what this game is as we go along this is
a ps2 game so hopefully it will bring
back some nostalgia
[Music]
[Applause]
let me know
[Music]
the game is very high okay I'm putting
it down mm-hmm why don't you was new
here at Gregory House are committed to
providing the kind of relaxation and
peace of mind that will make your very
soul tremble we will make every effort
to ensure that every guest who stays
with us is satisfied and what is your
desire here at Gregory House you will
find the embodiment for yourself your
hopes our dreams please make yourself at
home for this is the world that you
yourself have been searching for
oh do you need a room for the night
[Music]
I'm gonna put my game all the way up cuz
you guys I can put the game down waiting
for the right I put the game down like
very low now so he shouldn't be an issue
we shall see I might put the game down
to low now so let me know if I have
so I have been kind of obsessing over
this game lately this is a game that I
randomly found in like an exchange place
a long time ago oh look we got house
roulette because we we got the live
roulette dude only the premise for it is
so good it's based off a Japanese
animated show that actually you can
watch all on YouTube so it's great to
search gregory horror show and you can
watch all of it it's I I think it's
great it's made by balls I was looking
at them today what they made by ah I
can't remember I can't but you can
google it but anyway they made this
cartoon no no please don't please don't
I don't want I don't want to see it
again
and then because the the animated show
was like very low poly it was just
basically like cubes and it was
first-person it lended itself very
nicely to a video game which is this one
made by capcom so yeah we're just gonna
load it and see what where we're at
basically the premise of it is as you
can see it's called soul collector so
you have you're basically in limbo and
you're stuck in a hotel run by some
kooky people well they're not even
people they're kind of like animals and
stuff but every person who comes to the
hotel has a soul and they're little bit
lost they're not ready in touch with
reality because they're in Nimbo and the
only way for you to get back to your
reality is to steal their souls give it
to death in your dreams but every time
you steal someone's soul they then want
to kill you so the more souls you steal
the closer you are to the end of the
game but the more little live a little
like the more cautious you have to be
while traversing through shut up while
traversing through the UM
the hotel basically so we're gonna load
the game hmm
I'm on the third night the hidden truth
so we'll see whose souls we have to
steal but the mechanic that I love about
this game is that you basically have to
peep into people and then you get to
know their daily habits so you kind of
get to know what they're doing
throughout the day so you know how to
kind of steer clear with people but also
spying on them gives you insights into
how to take Souls from other people hmm
now is the audio too low on the game now
I think it is personally but you can
tell me I'll just I'll just wait for you
to tell me okay so we have the TV remote
which means that we're looking for the
fishy can I see it like whose Souls
we've taken okay so here's our map and
it shows us where everyone is oh my
golly
so everyone here apart from the little
mouse down the bottom because that's
Gregory he runs the hotels he's not
gonna try and kill me the cats cuz she's
kind of an ally on the left there and Oh
judgement boy I don't know how to
explain him the robot on the right
underneath the candle with a big knife
apart from them everyone will try to
kill me oh he's not on this floor but
there's also Gregory the mouse has a
little son they will all try to kill me
because I took their souls okay got that
cool so I have to see a clue of all
those people and what we're doing now is
we're trying to wait for the TV fish
because that's the next soul that we're
trying to take
yeah now you're saying for me to put the
game audio off a little bit does the
Dhoni bit okay I'll put it up a little
bit how how is here how does how does
this work for you this is that okay on
this person won't try to cure you cuz
she's just a saving frog okay so let's
try not get killed
oh they're ps2 stuff oh my god there's
someone right there that wants to kill
us we're gonna go this way
cuz we took his soul before we should
probably sleep or something though cuz
so we peep like this this could be very
bad though and if you move your analog
stick too quickly then they'll hear that
you're peeping in on them and they'll
know that someone's watching them
they'll come check it out see how to be
careful I'm scared that the freaking
chef is about behind me no it's not okay
good where was the chef gone I do like
that you have a map that you can kind of
check out though
oh and so the top left is like your
insanity meter someone's just opened a
door and I don't know where it's gonna
be Catherine is she coming out of her
room
yeah Catherine's come out this is not a
good place to be right now
hello Catherine sir Catherines that
right let's just go just go
chef's come back to work I know why
Catherine won't be see everyone's outs
again as it gets really hard there is
he's going upstairs
are you evil for stealing their souls um
I think this whole game is like in
between good and evil kind of thing
there's no right there's no wrong you're
in limbo everyone's here for a reason
everyone's a little bit messed up
including you
so there's that would you find this game
as I said I was just in game station
when I was a kid I used to just trade in
games to get new ones that's kind of how
we did it back in them days skies
because I didn't have loads of money
couldn't buy lows game so instead you
were trading your games was you finish
one to get another one and that's I
thought this game I wanted to get it
what what's that door oh this game is so
anxiety-inducing for [ __ ] sake to be
fair he's not gonna have me so I can
just go into his room do you know my
name I got green herb all that can't use
anymore can I use one of my mind if I
use one of these oh nice
yes I know what you're thinking resin
where do we put the shards of the heart
and the dollar sign after they've
shattered on the floor good question
on the junk pile maybe there's a lot of
stuff in that pile I think I've already
looked in the junk pile for someone else
so when you watch them whether that's
like peeping at them or looking at them
like this you can read you can kind of
hear their mutterings and that kind of
end chime tells you that's the the end
of their their dialogue cycle and you
actually write that down in your diary
if I remember correctly and it gives you
hints on how to steal the souls of the
people who are in who have come to the
hotel on this night but I've already
done two souls I just need to get one
more and that's the TV fish
the bar okay wait he was talking like
the TV fish right the bar shaped kid
didn't wake up see that's what I mean if
you move too fast catch the fish yeah so
shows up at the bar I think I know where
the bar is it's upstairs that's the
basement
remember Katherine's in the bar
[Music]
we'll just collect some more Intel can I
run in this game that's not running mmm
who can we spy on I mean everyone's in
their rooms oh I don't want to bump its
James so James is Gregory's nephew and
he's so annoying because he'll follow
you when he sees you and then he'll tell
you off if you try and peep on people
and so basically that mechanic could we
take it away from you for a little bit
until he leaves he leaves just after a
certain amount of time because he gets
bored for maybe I can just do this did
he just open his door and just go back
inside why did he do that
okay so they're wore in their rooms lost
doll is the scariest
I think presently
is younger like that's me no oh I'm just
gonna hide it here I don't know whose
room this is
yeah this is why she's so scary cuz
she's always looking for a doll she's
always crying
but her doll is so to the battle
Buckhead I know the fish comes the bar
but Katherine's in the bar how do I make
it come where I can make it come to the
bar how do I do that he's so paranoid he
just checks outside of his door I didn't
realize that oh no now she's just pacing
how am I gonna get out of this situation
Sophie I don't think you can find this
game it's really rare and it's very like
sought-after now so no but I do still
have my ps2 coffee back at home which is
kind of a treasure I got this game if
anyone's wondering it's on an emulator
okay how the hell am I gonna do that
[ __ ] it let's go let's go time it go no
no and I never know where I'm gonna
start when the freakin doors open oh my
god why is she so fast oh my god
everywhere no down the frickin stairs to
Egypt right
oh my god a safe room safe room you have
to watch that harvest or a horror shows
ah just taking my insanity so Catherine
even that's a kids game pretty sure she
can't all got the liver like yeah nice
right now
okay neck is on video nice [ __ ] you know
necklace on me oh my god you see what I
mean I never finished it as a kicker
there just got to too tough I just
couldn't do it I'm gonna sleep now are
shut oh seven this is a game for kids so
it makes sense where you find it more
cute interferring it's not supposed to
be like a horror game but for kids like
I remember this absolutely did scare me
do I have
why can I throw this on the bed
it's gonna put a home in here because
you know you never know when you might
need one
um yeah go lag right is it in the bar
yeah me think I need to go to the bar
and somehow like summon it there so I'm
gonna do that kind of like Happy Tree
Friends yeah yeah I come like that like
it's cute enough for you to not be
absolutely terrified but there's
something just not right about it
pagemaster scared me as a kid oh my gosh
skander tower there's a blaster the past
loved pagemaster so much was it horror
adventure and fantasy fantasy cool so
what I also love about this game is that
even though you have to wait until you
get the people's souls for the next
people to come in you still get to see
their rooms but they're just they're
just locked so you can kind of people
through the people and be like oh I
wonder who's gonna be in there yeah
okay it may be for kids it's very gonna
make you paranoid I agree
can I use this on here is that how I do
this how do I do you think alright this
is the bar right guys this is definitely
the bar I remember this is where I got
stuck as a kid as well so I'm just kind
of like oh I'm so determined I want to
do things how do I make it calm how do I
use this card Barney we gotta chuck it
in the bin you can offer it a bottle of
wine
I'm doing it looks like it's got to be
something to do with this I don't know
what to do with
[Music]
now I want to get the freakin thing you
know cheap
oh my god get it quickly oh we gotta go
we've got to go we've got we've got to
go we've got we've got yes to go down
the chute that makes no sense now we've
lost our soul man have we actually lost
it I am NOT happy about this who has it
don't tell me that freaking cactus man
has it
wait what's cactus mine on there oh it
doesn't have it do I have it who's got
the soul oh [ __ ] do I have the soul I
don't know I don't think you keep
thistles after I do have the soul all
this song I thought that if someone
caught you they would take your soul
maybe if it's the same thing catches you
it
they take the soul back either way we
still have it so I was an idiot for
calling that one back yeah see the
default option is no to go down the
rabbit shoot rubbish chute why would
that be stupid right anyway and now
everyone is okay if I go out the chute
it's anyone gonna be down here no I
should in theory be safe I'm gonna go
down here because it leads out to the
little outdoor bit
[ __ ] I spoke too soon uh things just
need to get back to my room I just need
to get back to my room yeah I know I
lost health but I always thought that if
if you had a soul on you and someone
caught you they would then take that
soul back
but maybe it's that if the same thing
you took the soul from catches you they
take you back I don't know we'll see but
anyway I'm gonna get
oh it's you did you manage to pick up
any Souls yes oh no I'm sorry who's next
yeah show me the new guests Swedish -
we've only got three more people or
things to steal from
Oh
[Music]
with it what did you do with my souls
you never gets hold of my soul
enough of your excuses stop tallying and
get them back yeah yeah screeching old
banshee
what was that get those souls back right
away look at them Gregory my beautiful
songs the secret of my beauty
okay this is a new part of the hotel but
we have never seen before
alright Gargery get it yeah then you
have evil laugh well done
[Music]
I control it's my brain is that just -
oh no I guess it was three cuz it's the
popper and Sun as well
so these are like kind of memories from
the reality because I'm stuck in limbo
which I thought was really cool tartar
it's like you know when you're alone for
too long your mind just thoughts go
crazy
oh okay so the when new guests come you
can go and talk to them then I'm gonna
kill you straight away because they have
their soul so they'll talk to you you'll
get introduced to them and then you have
to figure out how to take those so let's
go do that let's go meet the new people
wait who's in here there's two speech
box speech marks speech Oh
okay so it's something to do with the
boys screwdriver to get the boys saw his
Papa would lose a temper and use some
kind of strange technique what's that
when Papa uses the technique he breaks
down and can't move okay so how I get
the puppet so father must love his son
so much
I can't the dog and cat are good friends
okay let's go introduce ourselves well I
thought we could be introduced fine
maybe I was wrong well we know what she
looks like now so she'll she'll show up
on the map who's behind her is it just
her let's go check in on Catherine she's
sleeping right now what you got for us
Catherine we should probably think as
well just in case my son forgive me my
son I broke him down I can't come to
rescue you
she has a son even without me you must
guard the soul
that's what clock master oh okay so she
will have a son I thought that was gonna
be a plot twist then for us like I was
like is she
clock masters son's mom cuz that makes
no sense is this game yeah yes I used to
think it was so clever like whenever I'd
come back she'd be like I knew you were
you'd come back and all that oh good
your vote you tell us cool character for
a save character anyway wait what yeah
you'll be back doing it yeah what yeah
[Music]
okay so she's Ralph's into there let's
go meet the other ones
because it's 3:00 a.m. oh what's the
heat it's really difficult for us to see
hence why our eyes are like that
you
come on No the game thinks she's too far
away I can still see her though whatever
we know it's about the screwdriver that
the Sun has hello hello he's gonna run
when he sees us hello I'm gonna take
your screwdriver see he said hi hi who
are you so your name is Yaga lag huh my
name is my son nice to meet you
why don't what a great name
hey trap for horror fun fact never beat
in this game I used to play as a kid and
yeah is only ps2 but I'm playing on an
emulator so you can't get a PC as well
my daddy is teaching me how to find time
walk that's pretty cool
his name is clock master he's the great
and powerful master of times he's strong
but he's really nice too I want to be
just like him when I grow up
that's cute can I have your screwdriver
please
[Music]
my room lalalalala nothing happened
okay I'm not too sure what to do now we
could either try and find his dad and
show him the screwdriver and make him
mad or it might be a timed thing like
maybe we have to wait until he goes back
to his dad and then his dad gets angry
that is not the screwdriver is quite
this is steel you're screwed hell yeah
by the way just inserting some pipe here
there's a new music video coming out
this evening at 9:00 p.m. GMT and I
can't actually wait for you to see it
it's the first one that I've ever
rendered through unreal so yes it was
made in the game engine I'm very excited
I basically did it just for a practice
for the horror story but I'm pretty
excited with how I came out and this
song is a oh my mum's trying to phone me
I'll just I'll phone her back later
sorry mum um camera was saying now
where's the dad oh he's there he's at
the bar should we go to the part where
we've saved anyway so let's just go to
the bar and see what what his dad does
if he sees us with the screwdriver
oh yeah the song is a cover of beyond
the sea produced by the wonderful Jamie
from Horizon productions or at Horizon
productions of who runs horizon
productions he I think he's watching
this room this room has always just
baffled me I can't go in there come on I
like I can go in here it's all gold I
don't know who lives here but it's such
a cool random room did I come from this
way which way am I going I might come
back towards the steps no I am going to
make it cuz I'm a stupid doll face
doesn't come here it's a yellow half a
red harpes the best or a yellow I think
thank you for following JCM faces he's
sleeping oh the boys coming the boys
coming okay let's just wait and see what
happens this way I met Horizon
productions right now oh I guess I was
right and here he comes
I feel like we're ready for guessing and
it makes me very happy
[ __ ] gonna go down guys
know what's gonna happen
I thought it was gonna trigger a
cutscene I'm just gonna peek in
I was worried my son my son oh well why
didn't he have a door open oh yeah you
can hear the doors from downstairs in
this area they're coming they're coming
[Music]
wait I have your scooty didi bet I have
a screwdriver I don't wanna I can't go
out there because she's there
oh you didn't fail me thank you for
being a patreon there that means a lot
but now it's hard to keep up with all
the all the different channels I
completely understand that
it says - maybe I could use it here I
need a scooter did it over Ricky go into
the kitchen house chef isn't there where
is he oh wait there he is he's walking
the halls who probably come back in a
second okay maybe wait we're out in the
garden we should pick some herbs maybe
need to unscrew some things they would
need the screwdriver that's a good idea
well I mean he was fixing that clock
wasn't he so maybe we should go to the
clock Oh angel dog I reckon cuz I've had
to do it in the past way you just get
something you hold it out in your hand
and then you kind of show it to them
well your quip it basically and then
that's the same thing as holding in your
hands I don't know if we have to get him
on his own oh he's on his own now shall
we
[Music]
it's just quickly bypassed the son
because he's coming
who's it that who's in there
James is coming right we need to hurry
up
James actually coming this way he's so
annoying
Oh No okay I thought I crashed time um
let's just see what happens here deal it
from my I don't think I will
[Music]
okay
[Music]
go go go go go go little a little in
there
[Music]
you're a mincemeat
oh nice thanks for the host stretch of
Ahura walk hamburger nice good love me
ears
we're so what happens now what happens
so confused
where's the cook dead in he's up there
he's upstairs
to me people can't do this I think I
just have to run away from him which
means that I need to get some more of
this fast stuff absolutely everywhere I
can't do this who's behind me everyone
is behind me and in front of me okay
screw this I'm going to the basement
wait who do I have to worry about down
here no one
[Music]
I just get paid lost today it's not
health skin sitar it's it's my madness
Bob but don't worry it goes down for
every slowly what sanity my sanity bar
this eyedrops I can see it was gonna
wait til I find some stuff oh yes
as long as the spaniel is that way to
sneak I think there is actually I just
can't man but what it is I mean you can
just do this
I'm pretty sure I guess this would be
like sneaky
[Music]
Oh what am i doing
don't want to go mad no you don't want
to go mad that's true
[Music]
can't see his pulleys are in the way
your follies principal way okay we're
safe in our room our room is safety
safety
Wow heavy ones movie again he just gets
so hard so everyone just keeps moving I
just don't know what to do with this I
think what I have to do is just get this
screwdriver and then just outrun him
until he gets mad enough to do is time
thing I think I'm gonna go get some more
of that
I think Catherine's in here but we'll
just bypass this is the shop now this is
the tune so to buy things you have to
exchange them with stuff you've already
got so I won't speed up which is only
two starts it's not bad
give her an empty can and I'll get
another one just just a good measure
I don't know what to give my don't wanna
give them the Red Hat
this one baby
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo um okay
let's go back to the safe room now that
we've got all little speed ups
[Music]
where's the dad is he up on the bar
again
oh I spoke actors gunman walks feet
hmm what's James doing
there's no peephole yes I can't peep in
there I could see what happens if I give
it to the Sun or some with it
screw pops out okay let's see what
happens now I've saved the game so I can
always stop little [ __ ] I'll teach you
to be good my son okay oh okay that was
[Music]
I guess nothing I do have to show how he
has his breakdown okay I'm just gonna
see if he's broken down somewhere he
seems fine okay well in that case I'm
just gonna load the game I'll load back
we know not to go to the Sun with the
screwdriver we obviously have to go to
the - is this game
I don't want to say if I want to load
weight your avatars angry now she's got
a headache let me quit here we go
okay
so now we know what not to do
we just happy yeah okay we'll just go
spy on people
[Music]
why is house chef in oh it's not in
Catherine's room or fair where is he
then yes
[Music]
Gregory's are bad
I'm Gregory
what
this can tell you well I'm just gonna go
in through and spawn him from the other
side
oh my god - I did say from idiom part -
I need to do more live gigs
this
yeah he's still time he didn't do that
with it but I think we just have to
outrun him until he breaks down pretty
sure
what a day what a terrible bother would
you like to eat oh he'll tell me about
things so this is the creepiest one if
you try to pick her up be ready for a
shock of your life you know they say the
thing you're looking for is you just
went there by me perhaps it's for the
best that she never loads of food he
wanted me peep out either by the way
just so you know
[Music]
I didn't just stop the ps/2 : I'm
playing on an emulator ps2 is back in my
parents attic I think actually no I
think my dad still has the ps2 like in
the front room next to the week
don't I don't know just gonna wait for
things to happen I guess
see what [ __ ] only is dreaming about
[Music]
yeah see he's it's definitely I think we
just have to again to chase us Oh
Colin's got your ps2 right there
so you can see them or your memos here
so like what people do between this time
you're cleaning the changing rooms
tidying the library there's a lot of
sneaking when all the kiddies to love
this trying to fill up all these spying
on everyone she works out she works out
could it be that pillar that pillar was
when last doll is a scary self her
speech and manner is really different ah
they pick flowers together her in the
cactus gun man that's cute
nice back there okay perfect
shall we wait
[Music]
I think
[Music]
oh I can go down that way okay great a
lot of this game is checking your map
but it just it starts to get a little
bit unmanageable okay oh you ready guys
can we do this what do you think which
way am I going this way
okay my dude
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[ __ ] the way the same but the way I'm
hooked that no one's there back the way
I came
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
I should have gone down the basement
this is so intense
[Music]
thank you so much for the tip dad we did
it how do I go about that where did he
where did he die oh my god we gonna
hover yup go stopwatch no he's in there
with you
[ __ ] kids what am I gonna do now his
daddy is all I'm gonna save the game is
this game
pets got fives I don't even know what
pets copays but it's like this game now
I'm interested women save down here this
kind of reminds me of like a mixture of
I don't know like animal crossing and
stuff she knew you get to meet the new
folk that come in and kind of talk to
them and get to know them and their
routines and I like it I like it
I'm like what you were you I guess no
one's gonna give it here maybe went into
the library yeah I did
okay where's this kid he's down the
basement
Oh what pets Gophers not real but it's a
cool let's play Channel
Oh huh it's not real though excuse me
it's just double check okay don't get to
roulette boy please because I need to
get to you first
[ __ ] he got means get the soul while his
dad is still broken down no he's awake
[Music]
if they wish to become what beautiful
souls we must give up on being reborn
whimper grade
great so now is dad's backup we wasted
our time but we do have his clock what
does that mean
why do we have to sell coughing oh God
we don't have wait is it in our golden
stopwatch
now I'm the time master okay well that's
quite cool can I use it only once
all right so we're gonna do this all
over again now oh this is actually
annoying
wheredid thing is going to these come
down here maybe I take him down to the
basement this is so much easier where is
he now on you James
leave me alone James bugger off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go check around ok I'm good I'm good
yeah I know
wow oh my gosh good time that way how do
you do that it's so crazy oh my god I
can't believe James is loving this time
is money
[Music]
luckily he's not that fast I don't even
think I needed it speed-up
No
No oh god maybe I do need it
I always get stuck here
I know I'm good
[Music]
ok we did it again
now please son go on your own so I can
just get you
and music makes you feel a bit anxious
well I guess that would work for the
premise of the game what do I do
so use this I use this I've already
saved and it would make sense that they
gave us that so we could advance time to
get to him on his own okay now we just
have to get up without this little
douche here sorry
it's okay I know how to get by I think
unless we just wait for him to go into
his room yes
[Music]
ah we can carry on stairs where's the
stairs yeah yeah I gotta go come on
don't waste any time
wait am I going now just go just go just
go raise it this way
this one yeah here we go
your daddy if not around little [ __ ]
I'll teach you to pick up my son
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
so ridiculous
I'm gonna try it one more time and if I
can't get this one way I'm gonna call it
a night
the theory was solid that I know why
they gave us the clock I thought that
was just the helpers like if the kid
wasn't alone then we could at least
fast-forward time I guess we fast
forward it and then he woke up but we
didn't even the game didn't let us know
that he was awake rather irritating
okay so what do we what have we done is
the dad is he passed out so he's passed
out
do they have walk cycles no they have
like planned stuff to do during the day
so I guess yes but like very like loads
of little walk cycles that change
frequently there he is he's going down
okay so if we keep trying catch him
before he goes down it would be so bad
oh no okay it's coming in here so we
need two things have reload the game
okay so we're loading the game yeah yeah
whatever shut up right and then we're
going to speed up right now we're gonna
go straight down trying to get him
before he gets to them
[Music]
[Music]
yeah your dad's not around right now
[Music]
can I talk to you for a minute
screwdriver is a present from my daddy
it's really really important my son
her face is still scared cuz she's being
chased No
now
[Music]
well I don't know where to go Oh No oh
thank god stressed out the moment okay
what's that the audio buffering it's
just like an old game and I'm playing it
through an emulator so it's not gonna be
the best okay we need to find a way now
to get back upstairs to our bedroom
without bumping into anyone that
because they were going to go into the
games room
yep don't look around here
hey ke hey hey
okay they're gonna announcer oh but I
wonder what's up Stan was waiting for me
luckily everyone seems to be in that
room so I think we're good to go
oh I was like why can't I turn around
this corner because it's stairs yes the
path is clear we can go to a room don't
worry Michael I'll put this I'll put
this stream up like I do all my others
it might take us a while but they all
get up there eventually
okay let's go see death shall we come on
now
[Music]
it's you did you manage to pick up any
sauce Sweden hey thanks a lot here I'll
snap your card for awesome you've only
got two left I'm gonna have to go see no
guys just so you know cuz you've only
got two left I'll just peek in on some
people get some in your towel and then
I'll go but that's not the rest of me
tonight because you know I have the
music video coming out at 9 p.m. gmt
if you don't once we brother while
you're cleaning then just clean the
conference room some other time about
Gregory I'm gonna save the game before
it's too late
[Music]
good luck there buddy
[Music]
okay now we just have to wait for him to
walk past
hi pop that music video ah well he's at
the talking paper clip of collecting
souls yes I can see that resemblance oh
that's so weird weird call me deaf you
got recommended pets got videos pet soap
videos cuz you're talking about it the
phone it's always missing how do you
think they do hey Siri
oh hey Google is it hey Siri hey Google
my phone doesn't work dude hey Siri did
that make everyone's phones go oh
they're both sides go I want to come
outside
okay I think we can
but our shad stick you need to get some
voice recognition on your face oh I
don't even know where she came from
spy on this dude we still talking about
the Papa o'clock yeah I tell you what
guys I think I'm just gonna leave it
there and then you come back to it next
week if you're enjoying this game
because we were so close to finishing I
don't want to stop for a month no but
thank you so much for watching and
please make sure that you're subscribed
to my youtube channel because yeah
that's why you'll see their new music
video releasing 9:00 p.m. GMT very
excited amazing unreal well I mean it's
rendered an unreal I did put it through
from ear pro just to put a little bit of
polish on it but I'm very pleased with
what I was able to make and taverns in
there to do a guy's in Matera that
monster from the game perfection he's in
there so it should be it should be fun
that's okay
sorry wrong one razor
we're raising there I yeah like trying
to find me you see my little puppet man
in the background anyway
ah glad to hear you guys are excited
let's turn down this infernal noise yeah
that seems like guys are excited I can't
wait through it to be released
90m what's timeout seven two hours you
guys we have two hours two hours anyway
yes I'm glad that you could just come as
well montage I'm gonna say goodbye to
the people that can see in the chat and
I'll see you next week so goodbye
Montez goodbye call me dev goodbye
Michael Khan's Costanzo goodbye Jamie
goodbye our shadows seven goodbye hey
Kelly
goodbye a piece Teddy don't so you'll
love it yeah you might know love it
goodbye askin Tatar goodbye Sophie
Plummer age
goodbye Collin CWT who else anyone else
I think that's everyone I can see in the
chat but goodbye to anyone who I might
have missed very very sorry but I'm very
grateful that you were here anyway and
goodbye to anyone who was watching but
it's unable or was not in the chat Oh
goodbye Alex ba just saw your name Oh
and JCM beasts jo soo
jo soo and sk8 stickers UK what are the
name and did I say are two I'm just
gonna say hi to again good bye I to say
yeah say your oh say say your Oh No
I saw your shut up oh yeah join the
discord I do have a discord best way to
keep it up to me is probably to discord
it all through Twitter if you want to
see what I'm up to
Instagram is the best place but I'll
give you a little invitation to the
discord now just
the link make it so it never expires and
has no limits so everyone is welcome
here's a discord channel and here's my
Twitter
and I guess I don't keep in my Instagram
suite there you go okay goodbye Alex the
observer I don't know if I said that
before but goodbye everyone
and I guess you'll see me again in two
hours
have a lovely evening